francis mcdormand
is that you oh where what is you
hey huge fan thank you
your hair i like it yeah yeah i cut it
yeah it's kind of peter panty it's
really nice
i was thinking of doing something
different with this mop
hey maybe i could get the name of your
barber
no you're right i've overstepped point
taken
owen wilson we used to have the same
agent
she was never the same after you left
for uta though she misses you francis
please tell her i miss her today i would
but we're no longer speaking
yeah threw a hamster at her and she
didn't like that
hey can i ask what you're doing here are
you a south dakota now
no i'm not i bet you're wondering why
i'm here
why is owen wilson working in a sporting
goods store
i live here now yeah i'm out of the
movie game i was suffering from some
serious hypertension right here
yeah people always assume i have low
blood pressure cause i talk so slow
you probably did too huh no hey i was
stressed out
as you know it's not easy being an indie
darling
i just quit cold turkey stopped
answering wes
anderson's calls he calls too much he
loves me
gosh anyways when i got that diagnosis
my mom took control forced me to move
here and live a simpler life
cause your mom awesome no she's a [ __ ]
what do you think
good good what is that hey so you're
still making independent movies
uh yeah great money is it though
no are you okay yeah
you seem kind of down hey it's okay it's
okay to admit that making independent
movies is tough
not having the financial support or the
resources can just
wear you down and break your heart
here you i hope you're okay and not just
saying you're okay
don't worry about me i'm okay you sure
you're okay
i'm okay okay
repeatedly stop using my last name the
fans go crazy in here if they hear that
it's really good i'm kidding they don't
they find me and they're sad it's not
luke i just
why does everyone like luke listen my
time here
at the store has given me new
perspective and
i know you're married to a cone brother
maybe he could come up with a buddy
movie for us
we've got great chemistry you're feeling
it too right
no i'm not how about a caper movie
i'm just out of prison ready to do one
last job and you're my getaway driver
i've seen you got a van
okay maybe we're comps or or friends who
find a baby on the street
we name the baby ponton francis come on
i'll let you know
i promise all right
well don't wait too long i'm next in
line for night manager and i don't want
to do that